hi everyone welcome to this next episode
of your daily equation and today I'm
taking on the weirdest part of quantum
mechanics
it's called quantum entanglement many of
you asked me to show the math behind it
and and I will show the math behind it
it's quite straightforward mathematics
so it's kind of a gentle equation today
but one whose implications are
incredibly deep incredibly profound ok
so let me let me set the stage for this
idea of quantum entanglement it goes
back to the 1930s
Erwin Schrodinger is thinking about the
strange new features of quantum
mechanics embodied in his mathematical
description in terms of these
probability waves or wave functions and
the more technical language but it's
really a paper of Einstein's Einstein
again I mean like this guy right but
this is a paper with two colleagues two
colleagues Boris Podolsky and Nathan
Rosen and they write a paper that makes
use of quantum entanglement to try to
make a claim that quantum mechanics
cannot be the full description of
reality this of course you know Einstein
makes a pronouncement like that about
quantum mechanics and kind of rocks the
world are not just a scientific world
let me show you here here's the New York
Times right Einstein attacks quantum
theory scientist and two colleagues find
it is not complete even though correct
and that's actually a really good
description of Einstein's perspective as
I'll discuss toward the end of this
little episode on Santa's not trying to
say that quantum mechanics is wrong in
in any sense of making incorrect
predictions about the world he's always
saying it's wrong in the sense of it
claiming as some of its adherents did
and still do that quantum mechanics
gives a full description of the
objective world that it is not somehow
an approximate description
it doesn't leave anything out it's a
full description of the world Einstein
also described the end is claiming in
this paper that entanglement establishes
and Einstein and his colleagues Minds
establishes that co-op mechanics does
leave something out that's that's his
point but let me start by actually
talking about this entanglement itself
and it's right here in Einstein's paper
this is the actual actual paper right
here with Podolsky and Rosen I can just
thumb through you should take a look at
this paper because look at this page 1
page 2
just a few equations nothing too fancy
page 3 page 4 that's it four page paper
that has incredible ramifications and
there's there's nothing more complicated
in here than a little bit of very basic
quantum mechanics things that we've
already discussed but that in a
traditional course you'd covered in the
first two or three weeks and a little
bit of calculus a little bit of linear
algebra but nothing that say an
undergraduate wouldn't be able to just
eat this paper up read it and I'm always
surprised at how few people actually
read the original papers it's it's often
timed incredibly worthwhile to see how
the pioneers of a subject were thinking
about it before it became part of the
zeitgeist before it became part of what
everybody understands and even takes for
granted so you should take a look at
this paper but let's let's now focus on
entanglement itself and get a basic
understanding of what it is then I'll
show you the mathematical equations and
I'm going to talk about entanglement
well let me first talk generally then
I'll give a specific example what is it
in tankmen is a situation in which say
you can have two particles right and
they interact for a little while then
you turn the interaction off which you
can think about in your mind is widely
separating the particles let's say you
put one particle in California the other
in New York okay
quantum mechanics and entanglement in
particular says that it can be the case
that by performing a measurement on the
particle in California
you somehow affect the quantum state of
the particle in New York instantaneously
and similarly if you perform a
measurement on the particle in New York
if things are set up correctly you can
instantaneously affect the quantum state
of the particle in California even
though they're widely separated this is
an instantaneous effect so it can't be
that there's some influence that
propagates across the country and say
hey I've been measured in New York and
that's gonna affect you nothing like
that instantaneous influence it
widely-separated
locations and Einstein called this
spooky this connection he called it
spooky action at a distance do something
here
it affects something over there and that
is inherent to the formalism of quantum
mechanics so let me give you an example
concrete example and I'm gonna make use
of equality of particles called quantum
mechanical spin you may be familiar with
that idea if you're not
look here's I can think about it every
particle in the world has a certain
amount of quantum mechanical spin I'm
gonna focus upon an amount called spin
1/2 the details don't matter but what
that means is the particle can either
spin in a clockwise direction
which we call spinning down or it can
spin in a anti clockwise
counterclockwise direction which would
call spinning up these are fingers
fingers curl around the direction of
spin spin up curl around this direction
spin down and this is just a fact about
particle physics so this is not weird
well it is has its own weirdness maybe
we should have a little episode on
quantum mechanical spin but let's take
this for granted particles either spin
up or spin down now the weirdness of
quantum physics is that particles can be
in a fuzzy probabilistic mixture of both
spinning up and spinning down at the
same time so you can have a particle
that's like in this kind of a situation
up and down up and down 50% of each and
only when you measure it or interact
with it in appropriate manner does it
say snap out of the probabilistic case
and say spin up or snap out of the
probabilistic haze
and spin-down only through that
interaction through that measurement do
you coax the particle to have a definite
disposition okay that's that's particle
spin let me show you a little visual
just to make that bring this a little
bit more clear okay so here's a particle
it's an animated version of a being in
that 50/50 mixture being spin up and
spin down sort of blue arrow up red hour
down I then go ahead and I perform a
measurement and that forces the particle
to ante up have a definite disposition
in this case spinning down again if we
do the experiment another time because
it's a probabilistic statistical
description of the particle if it's in
this 5050 statistical mixture then when
I come along and do the measurement a
second time I may get a different answer
I might measure it boom it snaps out of
the probabilistic case and in this case
spins up okay so this is a feature of
quantum mechanics it may be weird in its
own right that the world is in this
nebulous probabilistic age until you
interact with it appropriately but
except this because now I want to go
further to the weirdness of quantum
entanglement which is this in quantum
mechanics you can have two particles
they interact say for a little while and
through that interaction they can become
into a quantum state that is of the
following sort each particle is in a
fuzzy mixture of being spin up and spin
down at the same time again that's not
weird but the weirdness is that they are
completely correlated so when this
particles up this one's down when this
one's up this one's down and vice-versa
and so there each and a 50-50 mixture
and now you can turn the interaction off
and separate them so let's put one
particle on one side of the country the
other on the other side of the country
in New York in California say so they're
each in this fuzzy mixture up and down
simultaneously now imagine imagine I
should say you go over and you measure
the particle in California and it snaps
out of the haze and spins up quantum
theory says at that very moment the
particle in New York will snap
the fuzzy Hazen spin-down even though
you have done nothing to it so your
measurement in new in California has had
a effect on the quantum state of the
particle of New York and of course the
reverse is also true let me just get
straight here so now imagine each in the
50/50 haze you go over to the particle
in New York and you measure it and it
spins up according to the mass the one
in California will snap out of the haze
and spin down at the same moment so your
measurement in New York has had a spooky
influence on the quantum mechanical
state of the particle in California so I
can show you that when visually here see
here the particles each and the fuzzy
mixture spin up and spin down and maybe
you go and you measure the particles say
on the left it spins up at that moment
the one on the right snaps out of the
haze and spins down do it again so
they're in this fuzzy mixture and now
imagine you go to the particle on the
right say it's in California measure it
spins up the one in New York snaps out
of the haze and spins down you can keep
on again doing this and if the weirdness
is that there's this spooky connection
each is an Apapa ballistic mixture of
randomly being up and down and yet by
measuring a distant particle you force
the particle near you say to become in a
definite state that's weird
right that's why Einstein called this
spooky this sort of spooky connection
between the particles now how do you
describe this idea mathematically well
the equations are really quite quite
simple so let me swap over here good to
my iPad and let me just introduce a tiny
little piece of notation so when a
particle is spinning up we sometimes you
know we could use the notation that you
may be familiar with for wave functions
I've used it in other episodes in terms
of you know sigh but we use a slightly
different notation so let me just get
rid of this
and we use a notation where we say if
it's spinning up this is how we will
denote the quantum mechanical state of
an arrow that is just in the upward
direction and similarly if this guy is
spinning down then that's how we denote
the quantum mechanical state now how do
you to note a state of a single part
this is all for a single particle how do
you even know the state of a single
particle that's in a mixture of spinning
up and spinning down well we can write
that as spin up and just add in spin
down and we need again to normalize this
so that the probabilities add up to what
I'm not going to worry about those
details here but the point is I now have
an equal mixture because in you know I
have a basically a coefficient one again
properly normalized in front of each of
them that's implicit there so I've got
an equal mixture of up and down and
therefore this is how we would describe
the situation in which we have this 50%
chance of measuring up and 50% chance of
measuring down good now that's the
single particle nothing weird at all now
let's go over to the case of two
particles not just one particle as above
and let's you say two different colors
for the two particles and so let me say
particle one say is spinning up and we
described it being correlated with
particle two spinning down and we will
write that in this way so when particle
one is in the Upstate particle two that
doesn't look very pretty
particle two is in the down state get
rid of these squiggles
it'll be confusing and now if each of
them is in this 50/50 mixture well now
let me go back to particle one and
include the possibility that it is
spinning down but if it is spinning down
that is correlated with the other
particle spinning up
so here is a situation in which both
particles are in this fuzzy mixture of
spinning up and down so if we look at
say particle number one it's got this
part and this part so it's got the
up-and-down quality particle number two
has the 50 up and 50 down quality but
the way that the mathematics is set up
is that the state of each particle is
dependent on the state of the other so
what do i what do I mean by that let me
just erase all the extraneous junk here
so it doesn't get too messy what I mean
by that is imagine now you come along
and you perform a measurement of say
particle one that's the one on the left
here maybe that's the particle that's in
California and you measure protocol one
and let's just for argument's sake say
that you find indeed that it is spinning
up you now know that this part of the
wave function over here we just use a
little green over here this part of the
wave function has now dropped out of the
situation because it involves particle
number one being in the spin down
orientation but your measurement found
that it's spinning up so you know that
part of the wave function is no longer
relevant and no more apply sometimes
people say collapse of the wave function
you can bring in all sorts of other
ideas like many-worlds interpretation so
let's not go down every single subtlety
at the moment so let's just use this
more conventional description in which
this part of the wave function has now
dropped out because it describes the
state of particle one that you know to
not be the case it's not spinning down
it is spinning up good now if you look
at the remaining part of the wave
function you therefore learn that
particle two must be spinning down even
though you've done nothing to particle
to particle two could be in New York
particle one could be in California so
here is the spookiness you go from the
quantum state in which each particles in
a fuzzy mixture spinning up and spinning
down simultaneously you perform a
measurement on one of the particles
today the one on the left the purple one
in California and that affects the state
of particle two in New York because now
the state of particle two is given
solely by spin down not spin down and
spin up and yet that change occurred
without you interacting with the
particle in New York that is the
spookiness and that is the mathematics
behind entanglement and in fact let me
just go back if I can Tyne Stein's paper
so Einstein's paper good I don't know if
you can see it but equation seven on
that paper gives the more general
version of quantum entanglement Spur
haps even just worth writing down that
equation
after all it's in Einstein's paper
that's kind of fun so he says look if
you've got two particles and he's only
doing one dimensional quantum mechanics
so he has a coordinate for particle one
and a coordinate for particle two and he
says look if that wave function is of
the following sort then there's a great
deal of Intendant going on here because
say the state of particle one is
correlated with the state of particle
two by virtue of the fact that this wave
function cannot be split up into say let
me just call it Chi of X 1 times Phi of
X 2 in general it can't be pulled apart
into these two pieces because you have
this summation over many pieces right
and only in the special case when say n
is equal to 1 or when it's so called
separable they can pull the wavefunction
apart into the state of particle 1 and
the state of particle 2 this is the only
special case in which they would not be
entangled because the state of particle
1 and the state of particle 2 are
independent of one another it's not as
though performing
measurement and particle effects
protocol one but in the general case
that Einstein looks at over here if you
were to say come along and measure
particle two and let's say you found
that its state is given by u 3 of X 2
there were these whole host of many
possibilities describing particle 2 it
could be in state you want or state you
two these are all quantum mechanical
wave functions but you measured it and
you found it's in state u 3 then you
would immediately learn that the state
of particle number one must be in states
I 3 of X 1 because you would have
eliminated all but one of the terms in
this quantum mechanical sum and that's
the spookiness the state of particle one
depends on Spader particle to the state
of particle 2 you do a measurement on
say particle 2 it affects the state of
particle one regardless of whether
they're interacting regardless if
they're near each other that is the
basic idea and that is the basic
equation of quantum entanglement let me
just finish up with one idea that I'll
pick up no doubt excuse me one second
I'll pick up in other episodes which is
being Einstein's view of this is that
the quantum mechanical mathematical
description may be accurate in as far as
it goes but he says there's actually
nothing spooky going on at all he is
saying that if you measure the state of
particle one and find it to be say
spinning up he says it was always
spinning up it was never in a fuzzy
mixture of spinning up and down at the
same time and therefore the correlation
with particle number two if particle 1
is up and 2 is now he says particle 2
always was down it was you're in
accurate Poppa ballistic description
that led you to think the particle is in
a mixture of up and down but it was in a
definite state all the time so he says
that the correlation between them is
nothing weird nothing strange at all in
fact John bel who will come back to
these episodes if we go further in
quantum entanglement I'm not sure we
will but if you're interested I
certainly will
he gave a an interesting example in an
algae making use of a peculiarity of the
the dress code of one of his colleagues
named Bertelsmann bertelsmann sucks a
Bertil noses character who always wore
socks of you actually talks of a
different color
yeah good hey just so happens right I I
to do it apparently brosman did I reach
into my sock draw in the morning and I
don't as long as I clean I don't care
just pull them out I don't worry about
it if they match and sometimes they
don't match and then fortuitously I
don't know this is too gross babies to
go I'm gonna do it anyway what the hell
so I'm gonna show you my socks all right
they're clean I tell you that they are
clean so here is the sock that was on my
my right foot here is a sock get the
dirt off if there's any on my left foot
near you so they don't match
I got purple and blue right and so
imagine I take these socks this is John
bells description I put these socks in
two different boxes and say I widely
separate them he says if you now go over
to box number one States in California
and you find it's a purple one he says
holy smokes you've now learned about the
state of particle two in New York you
know it's the blue one whoops
upside down you know it's the blue one
he says is that weird
no of course it's not weird right
because you've got a pair and they're
correlated they're not the same but
they're correlated and so the state of
the sock in California determines the
state of the sock in New York by virtue
of this correlation Isen says it's the
same thing he says the up and down that
you thought was going on that's nuts
going on the particle in California was
always up and therefore the one in New
York was always down that's all there is
to it now the quantum mechanics folks
they say I'd say neither than that
what's going on is better described
using a different analogy man you've got
a pair of dice you throw one of the dice
or one die you throw it in in California
you get a sex and throw the other in New
York
and you get a one or you throw the dye
in in California you get a four in New
York you get a three California get a
five New York you get a two and so on
they say that weirdness it's a weirdness
that Pappa ballistic qualities are
correlated not definite qualities if you
had a pair of dice that behaved in that
way would you think that's weird of
course you would think it's weird a
random result in New York a random show
in California or I guess there's a
random is out in California Rams of New
York are always connected Wow how could
that be
how could random distinct things stand
in this definite correlated relationship
but that's what quantum mechanics is
saying now who is right is Einstein
right the behind-the-scenes things
always have definite qualities and
quantum mechanics is incomplete because
it can't tell you those definite
qualities or is quantum mechanics
correct and say no no they don't have
definite qualities until measured or
appropriately interacted with and the
weirdness is that these random qualities
can be correlated even at widely
separated locations john bell comes
along and gives us great insight into
that anything most today would say that
the quantum mechanical picture triumphed
over instants version but you have to be
a little bit careful and precisely what
you mean by that
because the spooky action which is sort
of really what troubled Einstein that is
still there we believe but the
possibility that there might be definite
qualities behind the scenes that has not
actually been ruled out either if you're
careful about things so I'm not going to
go down that route but really what I
wanted to do today was give you the
little mathematical equation behind
quantum entanglement it's simply a
quantum mechanical wave function say for
two particles that can't be split into
particle 1 times particle 2 it's a sum
superposition again it's Rhoda nutrient
is linear and therefore if one solution
and another solution are added together
they will continue to be a solution and
we found it can have situations where
the state of one particle is so
dependent on the state of the other that
if you measure the state of one particle
it can affect the quantum state of the
first particle even if they're an
opposite
the universe okay that's the basic idea
of quantum entanglement that's what I
wanted to say today that is today is
your daily equation until next time take
care